e
e e
have those two no I've got
a oversight committee minutes from last
time
um Alzheimer's cannabis
agenda all
right Health and Human Services
oversight committee meeting for Friday
February 2
first and uh would the clerk please call
the role
because I don't have anything to call
the RO from I've written down was here
okay thank you that's what we yep I got
I will I will agree he is uh now next is
approval of the draft minutes from the
last meeting I think we have a quorum
and you should have the minutes so mov
thank you second discussion all in favor
no no no no discussion um you will note
on the very last page that I said the
next meeting will be on Friday February
28th which is what I thought it was to
be which I did had
forgotten everybody did okay okay
correct the date anything else any other
Corrections Mr chairman um just glancing
at this I I was I came in late but um it
doesn't indicate I'm there it indicates
when you came in oh okay thank you um I
think it was in parenthesis okay
and um one other question I had okay
yeah I'm all set thank
you anything
else yeah paragraph okay thank
else all in favor
iOS thank you
DHHS Commissioners report associate
commissioner Trisha Tilly
good afternoon my name is Patricia Tilly
I am an associate commissioner at the
Department of Health and Human Services
commissioner Weaver sends her regrets
today um and we are a pretty small group
so I hope you don't mind I brought this
up here because I have some notes that I
wasn't able to put on paper um so I'll
start by saying this past month has been
a lesson in adaptive leadership
uh as we navigate a flood of information
coming to us from Washington while at
the same time we are deeply engaged in
the legislative process in this building
and in the building across the street
and the budgeting process so lots of
things to do and while there are a lot
of things we don't know about where
things are going to land we are
incredibly grateful for um the focus of
our staff and Community Partners as they
continue to put their heads down and and
get the good work done so we are also
thankful um for the general court and
many of you and you sitting around this
table as we also navigate lots of this
uncertainty we've had lots of questions
um about Federal priorities and funding
and um right now we are all missing a
fascinating update from Henry Litman at
division 3 Finance as he talks about
Medicaid um and so he's going to be
diving into some of those unknowns but
um today what we have in front of you
from DHHS we have some of the great work
from our staff from therapeutic cannabis
to Medicaid to work on Alzheimer's and
other dienas today for me I've got two
updates for you um and then always happy
to answer questions as as you get so
number one there was an electronic memo
sent to you I don't think we got paper
copies we fall apart when John Williams
isn't here but um you had an electronic
copy about a YDC progress on the on the
new build um we have as you all know we
have passed that that in the fall we
passed the governor and Council um to
get to start the new build um currently
um we've had the hutter or HDR um cour
uh company out there doing work in
Hampstead they uh to date some of the
things that have been done is the
installation of temporary fences there's
been tree clearing if you drive by and
I'm sure you do you can see that tree
clearing we've begun the installation of
some of the storm water and pollution
prevention plan work we've done some
stump grinding any of you who' have done
construction know that this is not
exactly the fun part of construction but
it is all the pre-work that needs to be
done from drainage to Foundation
excavation and doing some of the grading
for some of the perimeter work so you
know we continue to work towards a com
um a construction completion date of
June 30 2026 so a year and a half from
now and we are are anticipating to be
operational by August 30
2026 um so after that we need some time
to um furnish and get everything going
but we're still about 18 months out or a
little bit less than that we also
continue to partner with the courts and
with others to make sure that we can
maintain the census that the new
building allows for as of today um we
have 12 youth at the snu center five
females seven males that FL that census
as you all know by now fluctuates on a
day-to-day basis it can go higher and
lower pretty quickly um and which is
makes that important for that design to
continue to be flexible to deal with
that of the mix of boys and girls you
know the number we know that where the
number cap needs to be but we do need a
little flexibility and as folks come in
and out and the new design helps get us
there so that's my update on
YDC um I'll go on the second update was
a request from representative McDonald
to talk a little bit about ALS and the
ALS registry as many of you know HB 576
sought to amend our statutes and I know
that Dr Woods or representative Woods
was interested this around how do we
think about developing a registry for
ALS an incredibly devastating disease
and something that we know that the
scientific and medical community and the
Public Health Community certainly wants
more information about um during that
hearing I didn't participate in those
hearings but you know it is my
understanding the department came in
with a sizable fiscal note um because
building new capacity to have a hippoc
compliance system that can take in the
information has generally cost us shy of
a million dollars of in this case we
came in at around 750,000 give or take
some some funds to build that system and
we certainly you know as I just spoke
with Senator gray we are in some awesome
de times right now and so the idea of
spending that kind of money is difficult
uh even though it is very much needed
from um a health perspective so we've
gone back to the drawing board
internally um as well to have some
initial conversations about what data
sets we already have that might be able
to help us get us closer to having a
better understanding of this condition
so that you know what would happen if we
did not you know we didn't build the
brand new system that's typ compant
where we could get the information
directly from from medical facilities um
what would happen if we looked at our
health dispar I mean our Hospital
discharge data htd our Hospital
discharge data and the all payer claims
or chis data those are the two big data
sources that we have um but neither of
them are particularly perfect they're
not there's information we could get
there but you know um they come with
some unique challenges the hospital
discharge data collects data from the 26
hospitals and the four specialty
hospitals it doesn't collect data from
primary care or other medical um
facilities or you know Physicians
offices or or urgent care it's also
based on discharges which means that a
patient can visit or be hospitalized
several time or you know with different
hospitals and sometimes you can't always
draw the connection around a diagnosis
when you're there for the claims for
what the service is that that person
received um it also um for those reason
it really can't be um used as a registry
to identify like an incident rate that
is my understanding of what the ALS
registry wanted to get at so that we
could sort of have a denominator like we
have a cancer where we know rates the
hospital discharge data could give us
information but it would probably be
incomplete similarly chiz is based on
claims um data um one diag nois often
has many multiple claims it's a good
resource to evaluate the cost for
procedures but not as good of a resource
to um figure out diagnoses or the number
of diagnoses or the rate of diagnoses um
and it also doesn't collect um self-pay
or direct pay so those that's where
we've started since this um the last
hearing to really sort of go okay what
do we have what are the pros and cons
what can they do and what can they not
do um and then I think we we're very
very happy to continue to work with the
committee of trying to think about other
ways that we can get to an end um that
may not be as pricey as what we we
believe a a full registry would cost so
um those are the my two updates for
today as always I'm happy to answer any
questions
or any questions for the associate
commission Senator Rosenwald thank you I
questions about both of those things you
talked about great um for I think four
years I was on the rare disease advisory
Council and almost every meeting we
would talk about whether it was a we
should try to get the state to set up an
ALS
register there was not agreement on that
rare disease advisory
Council that that was a good idea or
good use of State resources so I guess
my question is how closely is the
department working with the rare disease
advisory Council I know there are these
doctors at Dartmouth who are really into
it yep yeah I maybe Dartmouth will pay
for it yeah that's a great question so
we as many of you know who have been
around the ALS registry bill has come
back it's sort of a perennial favorite
to come we've been working closely of
course on the rare disease advisory
Council we have staff that are Staffing
that as well and I know that they've had
they've been on both sides of this issue
um you know I I am neutral in in you
know I'm happy to explore anything that
we that we asked to explore and also
describe what the cost would be to do
the do that work we've at we've worked
with Dartmouth Dartmouth um and that has
often been our recommendation is maybe
Dartmouth can do that especially because
they have access to all their own data
and even if they can't get a population
uh estimate they certainly will have a
better idea um as just the largest
provider in the state so I think those
are all reasonable questions to ask um
for this committee we wanted to just do
our due diligence again to look at the
data sets that we have and describe the
pros and cons of using them and and
describe what they could and could not
do between Hospital discharge and shis
okay and if I I'd saw repres I'd seen
representative Woods next
thank you Mr chair um um I'm new to the
committee and I'm not new to the ALS as
you know
um um and I'm ask perhaps a very naive
question and have to understand that and
I'll accept that if I am uh but it seems
like uh when we saw that fiscal note
that uh just from the data perspective
that I mean um let's say the cancer
registry now they have a grant or
okay if uh the like something like the
cancer registry uh they have a system
set up and a very good database and and
functioning it seemed like you know uh
maybe we could share this maybe uh
you're having a database over here uh if
we get a little bit of a grant or so
forth or just a few more funds we can
share all of that infrastructure instead
of starting like the fiscal note said on
this year's bill of whatever $800,000
starting denovo MH uh I mean it seems
like this would be an absolutely perfect
place to share some of that and disperse
and U some of the costs I think I think
that it's great for us to sort of dig in
a little bit deeper on there are um
obvious constraints you know the cancer
registry is mostly paid for by federal
funds it is in alignment with national
standards you know there it is a thing
um again because it and it's been up and
running you know in some form or another
for you know since the 1980s I believe
off the top of my head um I I think
there might you know we could explore
ways of like what would what would it
look like to do an extra module on top
of the existing structure I think it
would still be expensive at the end of
the day you know we've been doing
Registries for a while and doing trying
to do our data
modernization and the cost of the fiscal
note is about what it's been costing us
to do whether it's you know in any area
of Public Health to be able to get in
you know a hipa compliant system that we
can maintain that's on the same sort of
Salesforce platform as the rest of the
department the cancer registry as you
know is based out a you know it is a
department function we contract with the
Dartmouth we use you know a system that
is based on National standards so there
were a lot of moving pieces there to get
to you know it's not as easy like just
adding an extra tab on an Excel sheet
there's there would be a lot of work to
get to that I think the rare disease
council is probably a place to start
having some of those conversations of
whether that would be a good use of of
matching you know trying to match some
resources representative
Weber I was just going to comment on
representative Rosen wald's question and
say that last year the discussions were
all centered around having it based at
Dartmouth and the wheels I I was not
involved in the negotiations but the
wheels came off partway through I don't
know if representative McDonald
remembers more about it I know that um
um representative Murphy was um the lead
on that and just couldn't make it happen
and I suspect if he couldn't make it
happen it probably wasn't going to
happen so I know we worked very hard on
it
Senator Rosenwald thank you so on the
new the new Youth Center that's being
built in Hamstead I noticed um in
looking through the budget
that there's big increases in both the
next two years in the operating
budget um which surprised me since this
census continues to be really low I mean
we're spending over a million dollars
per kid per
year how much of that increase which is
like
million is attributed to building a
bigger space in
Hamstead
than perhaps the legislature originally
thought
I what's going to happen or is it oper
staff cost it's all staff cost it's
really and I and what um if Nathan were
here today if Nathan white were here
today he would um remind us that when we
were funding this current bium um lots
of conversations about YDC he would
suggest that it was underfunded in this
current banum and so we're trying to get
the next B anum's budget to be closer as
you saw we did a budget transfer today
that in part had money for for syc in it
so we're trying to get the budget closer
to what the cost for operations you know
for running a 247 facility you know the
the hamstad physical building is
actually going to be much smaller than
the as you know than the current
facility here but we would we anticipate
the same number of kids we have 12 kids
today we're going to anticipate 12 kids
a day um when we go down to to Hampstead
but running getting Staffing for that
24/7 and especially when we have to rely
often for with tempor staff or you
contracted staff um it it's been
costly it's my recollection that some of
it was a modest addition to the
footprint and the reason was the
conclusion that came a little bit late
in the game that 12 people aren't just
12 people right a group of them may be
in a gang that is the enemy to the other
group and as a result the facility had
to be broadened somewhat yeah you're
absolutely correct representative again
a reminder that the cost of the building
of the facility is not General funds as
you know it's arpa funds so the the
general funds that you see in the budget
are really around operating costs rather
than the building cost but you're
absolutely right which is why I
mentioned that we need to have that
flexibility because again you have to
separate boys and girls you've got to
separate their Sight and Sound
separations you've got to um move people
around and you know if you can think
back to the fall when there was a lot of
conversation about that um I think we
were using um the term beds probably in
a in a way that wasn't always helpful
that it's really not about um that we
may need more beds than we have youth at
any given time in fact I would say we
always need more beds than we have youth
because you've got to move people around
you got to have a sick room you've got
to do that and you've got to have that
flexibility I think that caused a lot of
um miscommunication or consternation
earlier in the fall as we walk through
that would you believe that once your
building started in Earnest it's not
stopped snowing in my front yard 300
yards to the south of this facility and
I will give you 6 weeks for this to stop
we'll work on that sir thank you when
yes Senator so is it are you guys
budgeting for 12 kids we are budgeting
for um a anticipated anti anticipated 12
kids there is flexibility to 18 which I
know is controversial but we are looking
for we're budgeting for the amount that
we are supposed to budget for
12 Senator gray on a different subject
thank you can is is your question on
this subject no okay Senator gray
okay a year ago I was concerned that we
weren't having someone look at the
department for compliance with both
state and federal requirements they told
me that there was an audit division in
your group that does all of that I would
like a report from them that tells me
what they've audited kind of you know
true a general nature and how many they
found to make sure that it is something
that is functioning and you know we get
a fuzzy feeling that you know all of
those laws that uh we seem to want to
pass are are being upheld so if I could
get that you know at the next meeting I
don't know that we can do that in time
for the next meeting but I'd love to
have you and our audit team to sort of
talk a little bit more of what that
would look like of what you would like
to see in a report um but we have a
robust dpq program that does some
internal auditing and also manages all
of the federal audits that we receive as
well certainly working on the chair work
working with the chair uh you can get it
on the the agenda for whichever meeting
is appropriate great thank you John
Williams this is for you wherever you
[Laughter]
want thank you
represented representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman um
getting back to O OLS ALS got to get my
my abbreviations correct sorry we've all
got on
the and getting back to ALS
um it's um you had mentioned it's a very
complex disease uh and the expense of
getting tracking any new uh illness
because because of the hipper
regulations and so forth is ALS in
particular very complex uh or is it just
because we we don't have the system in
place right now I think it's both I well
I would primarily say we don't have a
system in place we could you know um
cancer is also complex and that's why we
have a very um robust cancer registry
that you know looks at everything from
incidence rates and diagnosis to tumors
and staging so we have the you know
technical experience
um and certainly to work with you know
Partners or or vendors to help us build
something like that but it comes at a
cost to be able to do that and similarly
ALS um in terms of when it gets
diagnosed and when I go to those and I
know it's sort of a deep dive into wonky
data but like the the hospital discharge
data and that claims data you know picks
up the claim so it might not have a
diagnosis attached to it that's what
makes it complicated so you go in for a
feeding tube adjustment you know in the
late stages you might not necessarily
know by looking at that that database
that that person had ALS okay I follow
up follow up
um it's my understanding there's only
our best information that came out of um
the testimony was there's like 66
diagnosed cases currently in New
Hampshire is that that is my
understanding that it's relatively small
I I don't know the number off the top of
my head but yes it's it's you know to
the point of you know it makes sense to
talk about it at the rare disease um
advisory it is not as rare as some of
rare diseases that they discuss there
it's certainly known but it has a
relatively small number okay and final
followup yes follow up um so it's so
it's a complex disease but no more
complex than say cancer or others y so
okay thank you thank
you anyone else for the associate
commissioner representative Woods uh
more of a comment um is a complex
disease uh not in the same sense of
cancer cancer has basically a particular
cell type which is easily
identified and identifiable ALS is
multi-stem disease and therefore it's
much more complex because of the
multiple system interactions and that's
where the difficulty comes in so it's a
a little bit different just for
educational purposes
seeing nothing thank you so much thank
you I made a note to talk to John
Williams chair recognizes Jenny
Horan from the subcommittee of this
committee on Alzheimer's disease and
related dementia and you have an
wonderful what this is all one copy this
one copy yes yes it's it's got all of
our info in it so for the record my name
is Jenny Horan I'm the senior public
policy manager for the Alzheimer's
Association here in New Hampshire very
grateful to be here in front of you all
today very grateful to the chairman as
well for giving us a little bit more
time for me to get my feet under me
before I'm I'm really sorry but I
normally draft on a computer and I
listen in L hand but trying to
transcribe those notes was horrible so
I'm trying to take notes on a computer
and I'm new at it and if you could speak
just a hair slower Absolut really
appreciate it absolutely I do talk so
I'll I'll I'll make sure to slow down
but remind me if I pick up speed again
so I appreciate the combination we want
to thank the chairman for giving us a
little more time before I gave this
presentation so very grateful for that
um I also want to say thank you to
Senator avard he has been a really
thoughtful leader on the subcommittee
for us as chairperson so we're very
grateful for his time and energy as
chair I know you all have the report in
front of you we've spent the past year
or so under Senator aar's leadership of
gathering information regarding
Alzheimer's in the state of New
Hampshire regarding the types of
dementia care that exists instances of
abuse and exploitation that are managed
under the Department of Justice some of
the strains that caregivers are
experiencing across the state services
and programs that are available either
through the department or through adult
St centers um home and health hospice as
well as choices for Independence so this
past year has really been an instance of
gathering information for us to really
understand the landscape of the state of
dementia and Alzheimer's in New
Hampshire um so as you can see from our
report lots of really good data and
information in there Our intention for
this next year um and Senator avart has
directed us at our next meeting to kind
of really identify the gaps that we see
in the state and the system and then
we're going to start pulling that
information together to start working on
a state plan which is um encompassing
our duties as a subcommittee so we've
continued to meet since we fi finalized
this report in November we had some
really good presentations from the
bureau on adult and Aging Services as
well as from the detective sergeants who
run the silver alerts program and the um
Colonel Jordan from fishing game so we
are really excited to move into this
next phase of really craft
you know what is happening in the state
in terms of a state plan and what kind
of recommendations we'd like to make in
the coming year so I'm happy to answer
any questions did I hear you say that a
state plan is being worked on we we are
in the very early stages so we're
identifying the gaps right now and then
I think in the next coming meetings
we'll start looking at what that state
plan would look like and updating that
state plan could you send me and anyone
else here who wishes a particular email
telling us when your next meeting is I'm
I'm sure it's online somewhere but
absolutely no we plan to meet in March
so we're just finalizing the date but I
will send an email to everybody for
anyone that's interested in attending
our next meeting also um since I've not
seen this report before which doesn't
mean you haven't sent it out
electronically you V with 300 others
each day for my email rating um I'm
going to take this home and read it and
so would you be prepared to come back um
next month if any of us having read
something has a question or two
absolutely be more than happy to okay
note to John Williams note
two does anyone um on the committee have
a
question at this time I'm stalling for
the clerk here slowly
speaking so she can the more you talk
the more you don't say write everything
I say I don't pay attention to half of
it I I
just does anyone have a
question I don't write that down I do
Senator Rosen thank you I'm hoping to be
besides Glen Cliff forget about it which
does a great job old though it is um we
have a few
Jos pych units in this state do we have
enough geros psych impatient
capacity for meetings and need I would
say anodally and I can certainly get
back to you with more specifics anodally
we are all very aware that Alzheimer's
is a growing and significant issue in
the state of New Hampshire I believe
that we I'm going to slow down my
speaking I believe that we have 33 Jans
in the state based off of the last data
sources we are all aware of the strains
on our long-term you know care
facilities um and Alzheimer's and
Dementia is only going to continue to
grow in terms of numbers across the
state of New Hampshire so I think that
it's important to as part of our state
plan to really look at where those
numbers are going to end up and where
our capacity is in the state because it
is going to continue to grow and there
is a small amount currently of
capacity anyone else could I just get a
clarification on that one when you say I
mean we all understand that there's
small capacity are we at too little
capacity right now are we at
capacity um or do you have a sense of
that is that one of the things you're
still studying I think that that's
something that we're still looking at in
terms of what that would mean in the in
part of the state plan develop you know
taking those exact numbers and seeing
where capacity currently lies I know
there's been a lot of change over the
past number of years regarding you know
facilities being open and a lot of
adjustment in that so I think our state
plan will definitely be able to give a
more comprehensive understanding of
where those numbers are at and what the
capacity looks like thank you now
representative
Woods well I I think I'll withdraw uh I
think I'll I'll try and digest the
report first then see if my questions um
okay she'll be back and if we're
definitely going to have followup okay
good I'll I'll
hold okay thank you for your report
thank you and this will go tonight with
wine and
cheese at least at my house we're all
invited BR on
Jesus
and next chair recognizes Olivia May
Medicaid enhancement for children and
pregnant women quarterly report director
of Medicaid Enterprise development the
division of Medicaid services
DHHS did you get that all on your name
badge very okay good yes please
and I need two please if I may one for
myself and one for
thank you very much for the opportunity
to provide you with an update today on
our 12-month postpartum coverage in the
Medicaid
Program um the centers for Medicare and
Medicaid services had offered the option
to States in 2023 to extend Medicaid
eligibility for uh women who are in the
postpartum period to a 12-month uh
length of time
previously we had covered them for 60
days and uh the general court enacted
legislation in hp2 in the 2024 2025
budget uh directing us to submit a state
plan amendment to enact this extended
postpartum coverage period and that
state plan amendment was approved uh
November 3rd of
2023 as of January this year there are
45 48 states who have implemented this
along with New Hampshire and the map on
this slide just depicts that you know
the states that have adopted the 12
month
extension so uh because of where we are
in the timeline of this policy change
and then with claims data you know often
there's a 90-day lag for we for us to
have a complete claims history we're
only looking initially at women who
delivered in August through October of
2023 and then the 12 months you know
following that and then you know seeing
complete claims for about September of
last year so this is emerging data on a
small cohort and we expect to have more
information you know in future updates
looking at that small
cohort uh we uh examined the claims of
services delivered for these women 95%
of them did receive Medical Services in
that extended period
52.4% receive mental health or substance
use disorder treatment services
26.7% received preventative health
visits and 3.2% received a heart or
hypertention
service so I would welcome any questions
uh to help direct you know what what
topics may be of interest for future
reporting and again expect to have more
data as we have a longer run out from
this policy change I get the purple was
conson thing it means they have
unlimited it's not 12 months it's keep
going but it says hover over the state
and I've been hovering over Arkansas and
all I get is a hole so tell me what
Arkansas is doing in there Arkansas did
not adopt the option to extend
coverage
I'm calling Sarah any other questions
Senator Rosenwald thank you so as I
recall the income limit for pregnant
women is
250% um it's
2011% Federal poty Li okay so but it's
above the income limit for Medicaid
expansion so which is 138 so I I mean I
guess my question
is are we making sure that people who
are eligible for Medicaid
expansion
are made it or in that bucket since we
get a way higher Federal mat than just
saying oh you had a baby we can cover
you yes for 12 months at
50% yeah it's an excellent point that 65
whatever it is yes thank you for the
question it's an excellent point that
there's relative match you know in
different eligibility groups and when we
complete our federal claiming uh which
happens quarterly uh we do ensure we we
take the highest possible match u based
on eligibility group thank
you representative Woods thank you Mr
chair um in the medical community we're
very much aware of the ROI on this kind
of a program uh and judging from the
fact that I see uh and I wasn't aware
that pretty much we have 100% coverage
um have you H since this implementation
have you had a chance or any data about
the ROI on this
program so I think that's something
we'll be in a better position to examine
with a longer time Horizon out since
we're just now you know capturing the
first two months of deliveries that have
a whole year um but I think it's a great
a great point that ultimately we want to
make sure um we're seeing value um for
for expanding the the coverage
period um so that's in place I mean that
looking at the ROI is looking is that in
place it's in place in the sense that we
we will return to this claims data you
know which is always available to us and
be able to do analyses to look at I mean
I'm I'm interested in what your your
view on Roi is I mean one thing we could
look at is you know avoided um hospital
visits or Ed
utilization um preventing higher cost
Services by being able to deliver you
know more preventive care by virtue of
having this this coverage it's never
super simple you know to find Roi in a
Medicaid Program but I think um the
spirit of that analysis is certainly
ending you have other states to compare
right that's a good point when I helped
in the house with Medicaid dental there
were numbers of people who wanted it
because they saw this from a
compassionate perspective how I was able
to win over some others was very simple
spend a little bit now or spend a lot
more then I hated to have to argue on
that basis but I wanted their votes more
and actually some people bought it
however some people came back to me and
said it's all well and good to say there
is return on investment show me real
numbers so I would suggest that after a
year or so you come back with that and
the reason is not that I don't believe
it I do believe it but there are people
who don't and I want to be armed with
that absolutely thank you and
representative Weber and just as a
corollary to that that might also be
helpful when the next program comes
along when we say gee dental cost a lot
more the first year while we were fixing
people who hadn't had care but look at
what's happened on year 2 3 4 five and
six and similarly with your program if
we can show that there are similar good
outcomes it might actually give people
an impetus to say oh yeah they're right
they're not just talking out of the top
of their heads thinking that this is
happening we've documented
it if you could pass that one along to
ra Mr Litman absolutely and let him know
because he regularly shows up here and
uh we've had Medicaid dental for a bit
now that would be very helpful and thank
you bring that up anyone else for Miss
May
no thank you thank you for having me
and we bring back Michael Holt
administrator dph Department of Public
Health of the DHHS therapeutic cannabis
program 2024 annual data
report uh thank you very much for the
record my name is Michael Holt I'm the
administrator of the therapeutic
cannabis program with the Department of
Health and Human Services I'm here today
to present and answer questions about
the annual therapeutic cannabis program
uh data report uh you should have all
have that in front of you um the report
is required by Statute RSA 126 X10 um
the report includes data on patients
caregivers and certifying providers who
are active in the program as of June
30th 2024 so we uh do this report based
on uh State fiscal year um the report
also includes um summary data from the
alternative treatment centers um based
on their annual reports to the
department um if you want to take a
quick look at page three of the report
gives you a snapshot of patient growth
over the years um we have seen growth um
since the program was established in
2013 and then operationalized in 2016 uh
but that growth is slowing
um as of June 30th 2024 we had
1475 patients uh registered with the
program um this is this is the lowest
number of patients uh nationally for a
uh State per capita for enrollment in a
in a medical program um that's data not
in the report but information has come
from uh other uh the marijuana policy
project has done a study on that um so
it's about yeah 1% we have 1.4 million
uh population 14,000 patients um it is
the lowest in the
country um so patient registrations have
plateaued over the years as you can see
um you know 2019 2020 we had uh saw
increases of 29 to 30% in terms of
patient registration in 2024 um there
was a
3.7% increase in
patients um so the uh is it
we wonder is it saturated or are there
still barriers to access uh accessing
the program here in here in New
Hampshire um the majority of patients
are in their 50s and 60s this is
expected due to the you know the age of
chronic disease states that are uh that
are listed in the statute for qualifying
conditions we also have a very small
number of minor patients on the program
um there are seven minors as of the uh
report date uh last uh last June um
so the uh the guard rails to
um appropriately certify minor patients
for the program are uh are
strong the vast majority of our patients
uh 83% are certified by their providers
for a pain condition if you look at page
uh uh 12 and 13 that starts the um the
uh uh the qualifying conditions section
of the report other common conditions
the the top conditions are PTSD at 22%
insomnia at 7% uh and cancer diagnosis
uh at 6% of the registered patients um
interestingly this this data is not
included in the report but um we have
approximately 450 new patients on the
program since October 1st that have been
certified under
new condition categories that were voted
into into place by the legislature last
session um so we have 400 new patients
um certified uh as having generalized
anxiety disorder and we have another 50
patients uh certified under another
category um of a provider discretion
basically any other condition that a
provider believes based on their
clinical opinion or the benefits out
weigh the risks so what this shows to me
is that there's an immediate impact um
on program numbers based on on uh
legislative action um to uh increase um
uh or expand uh condition types um
you'll notice uh there are no bills this
session uh that would propose to add a
new qualifying condition um the uh the
work done last session which allowed
providers full discretion to uh certify
patients over 21 mind you um for any
condition where they uh uh think it is
more beneficial than the risks um in my
opinion that's that uh will essentially
stop the the the legislation going
forward to add one condition here or one
condition
there
um so on uh on page eight we have a a
graph about designated caregivers um so
the uh the number of caregivers in the
program has increased dramatically um
since uh since 20120 essentially
registration has uh has doubled from
about 500 to over a th000 um this means
the patients have better better access
to the program via their caregivers um
caregivers are allowed to legally
possess and purchase cannabis on their
patients behalf um the program waved
caregiver application fees during covid
and then went back into uh rulem um and
eliminated the fee Al together um thus
reducing a barrier um and then uh the
legislature removed a requirement for
caregivers to undergo a state and
federal background check including
Federal fingerprinting that was a $50
charge and also created a barrier for
caregivers to not want to be on a
federal registry say um based on their
their family or loved ones cannabis use
um so these are again these are aspects
that the um that the the legislature has
uh uh passed to reduce barriers to
access uh and make patients uh lives
better with respect to uh this
program
um page nine talks about uh certifying
medical providers uh there are over 14
100 medical providers um who have
certified at least one patient um as of
the report date uh we've seen increases
in provider participation uh throughout
the history of the program um but it is
still a common challenge for patients to
find providers to certify them this is a
common uh question that we get um asked
at the department on a regular basis um
in New Hampshire any provider is
authorized by law to certify but they're
not mandated to certify of course um and
many choose not to um so this is a
particular challenge for uh a a portion
of our population veterans in particular
um who are receiving uh all of their
medical care from the Veterans
Administration uh those providers are
federally prohibited from certifying
their patients um so we and we've got
about 9% of our patient base um uh who
are who self-report as veterans um so
that population is a population that has
uh that needs to go out into the
community and find new doctors if they
want to participate in the program
because they don't have access uh
through their regular medical providers
that's not a unique problem um but it is
a particular problem for that for that
group um let's see moving on to the
alternative treatment center information
um I can share some highlights uh
product types cannabis strains have
increased across the board over the
years including this past year product
costs have come down across all the
atc's um over the the past year
uh however cost does Remain the number
one concern of patients
um because of the proximity to other
states that have legalized cannabis um
in such a way that costs are very very
low outside of New Hampshire um high
prices here still contribute to a
crossborder um accessing of cannabis and
cannabis products to uh New Hampshire
patients um
more than 30% of registered patients in
2024 never went to an apire ATC they
they are going out of state um
especially Maine where uh the medical
marijuana program is not regulated by
the state uh and thus because of its
lack of Regulation uh costs are very
very low for cannabis
products um the ATC uh information goes
on um between 6 and 24% of patients have
provided Effectiveness data um positive
outcomes are reported uh by 78 to 99%
this is on page 15 um negative outcomes
are reported by 2% or less of patients
providing that
information uh and another area I'd like
to highlight is uh the alternative
treatment centers patient affordability
programs um nearly 30% of the patients
served by the atc's are registered with
the atc's patient affordability programs
this includes uh patient uh recipients
of Medicaid um and individuals uh
receiving SSI or SSDI um the atcs also
allow um have programs for uh financial
hardship in general U they all provide
discounts to uh to Veterans um in 2024
these affordability discounts totaled
more than $1.1 million um across the uh
the three ATC
operators um I'm happy to uh so yeah the
program is running smoothly um uh
efficiently registry ID cards are
getting out timely according to uh
statutory time frames um and I'm happy
to take any
questions I have one on page four and I
I certainly don't mean this in any
disrespectful way but I notice a
significant disparity between Coos and
Hillsboro and is there something that we
might need or want to know that could
explain that uh so this is this is an
area where we could present the data uh
somewhat differently on basically
adjusting it for um the age of the
population um that disparity if you will
is directly related to the uh the age of
the population in those uh two counties
that's helpful thank you anyone uh
Senator gray
so it I believe that you said that there
were one of the lowest in the nation for
people taking advantage of this
program the hypothesis that I would came
up with was that it is cheaper and
easier to get it not through your
program and it appears that your later
testimony saying Main's
price uh even though it's illegal to
bring it across the back across the
border it help help to justify that
hypothesis want to comment or I would
agree with your assessment um I also I
also believe that the uh the development
of the program over the years as a as a
very restricted program limited program
um in terms of the the the number of
qualifying conditions and the types of
qualifying conditions um had a uh had an
effect to uh reduce uptake along the way
um and as other states uh developed
their you know legalized cannabis for
adult use
um patients who could not patients
people who were self interested in
self-medicating perhaps you know did not
need this program because they were able
to get it out of state um when they
couldn't access this program based on uh
the qualifying conditions that were
listed in the law um PTSD was a later
add-on um uh chronic pain you know as we
as we see you know 83% of our patients
you know are certified for a pain
condition um chronic pain didn't come um
was added to the to the list until uh
2019 I believe so 3 years after
operations so um but yes I I agree with
your your assessment of the the the
levers thank you representative
McDonald thank you Mr chairman uh
looking at page 11 uh and just scanning
through the report it seems like
statistics seem to follow counties by
population it does and um but on page 11
uh Marx the third largest county but
Grafton seems to Eclipse it in terms of
number of providers and I was just
wondering if you might know why that
is Dartmouth oh Dart okay Dartmouth and
okay thank you that answers
it and while we're on the same page I
see 404 different
providers only have one person certified
but we get down to the bottom of that
column and 17 providers have a 100 or
more I'm my guess is this depends on
their medical Subs specialty and if that
is true could you break out who are the
most frequent providers by medical Subs
specialty uh if you go to page 10 um the
page before it does we do list
Physicians by specialty um Pas don't
have Specialties um so they're not
included on that list um and you can see
that uh the top two are Family Medicine
Internal Medicine um and that aligns
with that aligns with the top of the
graph on the bottom of page 11 where you
know if you look at the first two
categories of patient certified 1 to 10
or 1 to n the vast majority over a
thousand of the of the of the 1,400
providers um are certifying between one
and nine patients these are these are
patients going to their pcps right and
being certified in the way that the
program would much prefer people to be
certified you know in uh where talk to
your PCP about your interest in the
program integrate this alternative
therapy uh with um your uh your regular
Continuum of Care with your uh with your
uh primary care provider or your
specialist and so the the top of that
graph I think is very instructive about
the model that New Hampshire has chosen
um to focus uh the true Bonafide
provider patient relationship uh and and
enforce that in this program when we get
to the bottom of the list um there are
doctors and providers who have business
models that advertise cannabis
certification um and these are these
these providers are are are few in the
state of New Hampshire unlike other
states like Massachusetts where not
everyone but they have a different model
and that the Massachusetts model uh
lends itself to pot doctors uh that are
issuing cards based on a Health visit um
and a claim of back pain right um in new
New Hampshire does have providers who do
advertise cannabis certification as part
of their service array but they're a
limited number those names are in the
public space um these other providers
that other providers who don't want to
certify their patients um send them to
and so that's why we see some of these
providers you know 17 in total having
more than 100 patients
um so that that that explains that that
those those numbers um it doesn't answer
your specific question about their
specialty um uh but it does explain the
uh the category
itself my guess it would be the more
painful the disease is the more likely
this could happen whereas many people go
to their PCP for a lot of other
different things where this would not be
in
play runny noses and things like that
scrap Doos yeah right okay any yeah
Senator rosenal thank you very much we
know that cost is a barrier for the
patients
um but the good part of being in this
program
is there's kind of confidence about the
quality of the product that's free of
pesticide
and
herbicides uh is there anything that you
would recommend that we could do to
lower the cost
barrier the program and the department
is not in a position
to say we want to increase patient
numbers necessarily we don't want more
people being sick we want to be able to
reduce barriers so that if patients want
access to the program they can have a
conversation with their medical
providers and their providers have
confidence uh in this as an alternative
therapy
so but but more numbers more more
patients mean that three companies that
sell cannabis and cannabis products uh
have more patient to sell their product
to that creates economies of scale uh
that creates lower prices so there's a
direct correlation between the number of
patients on the roles the number of
patients who actually go to the New
Hampshire atcs and don't go out of state
uh and the cost that the atcs are able
to um uh charge for their products so
there are in this legislative session um
a number of bills um that are being
proposed that would have a
midterm impact
on
prices uh one of the bills would allow
uh the atcs to Outsource nontox non-
intoxicating hemp derived cannabinoids
like CBD instead of having to spend
their resources growing it themselves so
if they could Outsource that uh CBD is
legal federally if they could Outsource
that um they could include CBD in their
products at a much much lower cost to
patients um so that's a bill that's uh
that's that's uh was heard before the uh
hhsa committee um pass and I I'm not
sure if it's passed the full house yet
or not um there's another bill that
would allow the atcs to
uh uh do conduct Greenhouse cultivation
Greenhouse cultivation certainly a large
capital investment in the facility but
the production costs once established
come way down because of electricity you
they'll be using the sun to grow product
the plant as opposed to uh um uh
artificial light um there's another bill
that proposes to allow the alternative
treatment centers to convert to a
for-profit status um based on the vote
of their boards right it's not a it's
not a faded compete that they all would
the the boards would have to vote on
that again and and that would allow them
to uh they say uh to reinvest um uh
restructure their businesses to reinvest
in uh uh in their programs here um and
lower prices so there are there are
lever that are that are open to you as a
legislator to um to act to reduce those
those prices to patients um and uh we
don't you know obvious we don't take
positions on those bills but I'm here to
say that I believe that all three of
those will lower prices for
patients you're
welcome representative
Weber am I right chairman McDonald that
the um the grow houses and the um uh
cannabinoids I think went went through
the house and went onto the consent
calendar I believe so and the for-profit
status was wrestled with a bit more and
maybe awaiting an appearance on a
calendar is that HB 54 Mr Hulk do you
remember I believe it is I think we exec
that just this past
week no I think it was yes I believe it
was U unanimous 18 to Zer in favor of it
and it will go to the house next maybe
it was this week I'm not sure it was
either this week or last week actually
that may been the bill yesterday I'm
trying to remember I know that we all of
the Cannabis bills are before our
committee we passed ex favorably except
um the one that we give veterans the op
the free card that was the only one we
did not approve everything else we did
approve from mainly representative um
Thomas was the sponsor was all of those
so my my point was that they're all off
to the Senate yes yes and will be
arriving shortly I would add the
department has done its part we've we've
never raised a fee in the history of the
program we've eliminated fees or low
lowered fees um in fact uh recently
we've um the legislature passed you know
allowed for a three-year certification
um instead of an annual certification we
didn't raise our rates our fees so it's
$50 it used to be $50 every year um it's
now $50 for three years um and so I
believe all these all the these efforts
the lower prices you know from the atcs
our not low raising our fees have
contributed to the the the small but
steady growth and um and not a decline
in in patient uh
registrations seeing no further
questions thank you so much thank
you I'm on next I'm on your I'm your
next item on the agenda as well sir you
can stay you don't have to you
know annual report of the therapeutic
cannabis medical over site
board thank you again for the record my
name is Michael Hol I'm the
administrator of the Department's
therapeutic cannabis program
um i s my regards from The Honorable
Jerry kerk former House member and he's
the current chair of the uh therapeutic
cannabis medical oversight board he
asked me to present this uh report to
you talking into coming I hate to
subpoena him I miss the guy he uh I
asked him if he wanted to come and he
said that a three-hour roundtrip drive
for a five to 10 minute presentation was
uh uh oh and he was taking care of his
grandkids today that may be a more
compelling uh reason to not uh to not be
here um he did uh he legitimately sent
his regards and said he would love to
see all of his friends here
again um so um the board met three times
in 2024 and focused on legisla
activities primarily as well as uh um
educational material um legislatively
they reviewed proposed legislation for
the 24 session the available lsrs for
the 25 session um they researched uh in
medical literature various topics uh and
uh then provided their clinical
expertise and guidance through testimony
of the legislature um last year and this
year uh there are some broad themes in
terms of the board's positions on on
various bills um they uh they focused on
on on bills that had CL clinical
components um including bills that as we
talked about previously would have added
uh new qualifying conditions um it's not
a rubber stamp uh they they do do their
due diligence and and and looking at
those conditions they um they uh they
supported adding generalized anxiety
disorder but did not support adding uh
Eating Disorders generally
um and as I mentioned earlier they did
support the bill that provided uh
medical providers uh discretion in
certifying patients for any condition
based on their clinical opinion
basically it sets up a a different
approach um uh providers have to sign on
a dotted line saying that in their
clinical opinion um benefits outweigh
the risks um they also uh focused on
bills that impacted patient access to
the program because if patients don't
have access then they can't gain a
clinical benefit from the program so
they oppose limits on THC concentrations
in therapeutic products they oppose
criminalizing possession of unsealed
therapeutic cannabis containers and
vehicles for patients uh they oppose THC
blood concentration in patients due to a
lack of a scientific evidence um and uh
and they they supported home cultivation
uh for uh for patients uh inste of r W
actually that reminds me home
cultivation um is is another bill uh
common perennial Bill and coming and it
comes every year and that is a bill that
would absolutely lower costs for
patients it would not increase the sales
necessarily to the atcs um but it would
certainly a lower cost for patients if
they could grow their own um and the the
tcob um has has supported that policy
change for a couple years now um that
was one that was one we voted on
yesterday yeah that's right that's
right on your
way so uh the bills this year 2025 we
we've uh mentioned them they they
supported um the various legislation
that improves ATC operations um to the
benefit of patients primarily lowering
costs uh the hemp dve cannaboid Bill uh
the greenhouse cultivation bill um and
uh like I said home cultivation and uh
possession limits uh to increase the
patients access to cannabis and so they
don't have to drive as many
times far away over an hour to a an ATC
location um the educational material
that they focused on this past year was
the risks of cannabis use in adolescence
um they uh the board finished their work
on this um they conducted L literature
reviews scientific evidence about the
specific risks of cannabis use to this
specific vulnerable
population um and uh the board also
worked on messaging uh this uh risks to
the uh to the population uh this work
product is penic one in the report um
and the department is now working on
converting the information gathered into
uh uh digestible population friendly
documents you poster and brochures to be
available at the alternative treatment
centers um to make available to their uh
their uh their patients there um I
expect this work to be done in a couple
months
um happy to answer questions about the
operations of the therapeutic cannabis
medical oversight
board seeing no questions thank you for
your reports thank you very
much and uh off the agenda until I just
put it on Senator gray for a suggestion
for this committee to consider enacting
one of the things that we are not
overseeing is their
budget I think that right now the uh
state is projecting that the lapse is
going to come in uh $47 million less
than what the laps would normally come
in and if I look at
HHS that could be as much as $15 million
of that from that one Department um so
we need to find a way to at least do
some kind of oversight um of their
budget
uh certainly every two years it becomes
a big thing if they don't make the laps
um and it affects multiple departments
so I'm not saying how it should be done
or what it should be done I think that
Mr White has some ideas uh and some
discussion points and so I'd like to see
it on the agenda for the next time uh to
discuss how we would do that
oversight representative
Weber and I just want to make a p
comment that although it looks like we
may actually finish up early this time
it's the first time I can remember that
happening in three or four years this
committee is strained to the limit for
the amount of information it can take in
think about process deal with refer to
other people and comment on and we have
a very rigorous budget process in both
the house and the Senate whose job it is
to focus on exactly what Senator gray is
talking about with people who work with
those figures every minute of every day
or practically and most of the night as
well and I think for this body to take
that
on uh with our far more limited
knowledge except for those members who
actually sit on the relevant budget
committees in the House and
Senate is um a duplication of effort
with far less useful Personnel to take
it on but that having been said I am
more than willing to discuss it further
at whatever agenda it appears
on representative Woods um thank thank
you Mr chair I I was going to make
basically the same comments but uh would
the senator have any particular areas in
mind uh that we could be attentive to
where the our role would enhance the
process as we examine the budget and if
so what would those areas be I if I look
at the Senate uh finance committee
certainly historically there's been two
of us from the Senate finance committee
on this me you know the Senate Finance
does not go down and try to stay up on
each one of the Departments and if I
look at the charter of this
committee okay maybe it needs to be
broken into two if it's you know maybe
we need to have two meetings a month
again I want to have a discussion
because I don't believe that finance
committee either in the house of the
Senate is the right one to provide
oversight when I have a committee that's
charged with that
oversight so again we'll have the
discussion next month you know everybody
can air out their laundry uh but as a as
a finance committee you know I don't go
into each one of the Departments you
know for a$1 15.2 billion budget you
know and oversee it okay I think that
there may be something that we can do um
of a smaller nature a report you know
that that won't take a lot a lot of time
uh but when I come to the last six
months in a budget cycle last five
months in a budget
cycle and I'm maybe I don't know what
the number is I may be $15 million short
in my
laps I don't think we've done our due
diligence
so I'm willing to wait till next month
would you suggest that the chairman of
house finance be part of this
discussion chairman of Senate Finance
some folks some DHHS and ourselves in
this um beginnings of threshing it out
certainly I would not you know tell the
house what to do the chair of Senate
Finance is here the ranking member of
the opposition Senate Finance is here so
again throw it out there this month and
have the discussion next
month Senator thank you I mean I I don't
disagree at all with Senator gray
that we need to keep more on top of
how the spending of the
Appropriations is going over the two
years what I have found is
that the executive branch is not
always
cooperative and I'm sorry to say that
but if you
ask how's the laps
looking it looks to us like it's going
to be $40 million less we sometimes hear
oh no it'll be fine so I hope that we
could get the executive
branch to
be
participating in that because they're
the ones
who are you know they put the hiring
freeze on they control the lab
they do stuff behind the curtains
that we tend to find out about later
and
um I'll just stop as one who likes to
try to find middling
ground uh taking to Heart both Senator
gray and representative Weber's comments
I think at least this committee should
be involved to some degree in looking at
it I'm not suggesting necessarily we
take it over but right now we're way
over here where we don't do anything
with the finances we look at policy we
receive reports and yeah I think we
should do some more somewhere in the
middle
um perhaps next month we can carve out
at the end of the meeting some time
to look at this more
fully representative
McDonald one suggestion I would have is
perhaps you want to talk to Chairman wer
on the finance committee do that sure
and um see what he thinks of it I mean I
know right now they're and as the Senate
soon will be stretch pretty thin with
with this whole process but uh whether
they became a formal member or not is
questionable uh in terms of its
feasibility right now but maybe you at
least want to run that idea by him and
see what his thoughts are we'll do Mr as
well as representative Edwards is I was
to say representative Edwards chairs
division three he's not here right now
because they're in the middle of the
budget process but he is in a position
to talk very knowledgeably about the
depth into which division 3 plums The
Depths and as one who was watching
somebody do it the downstairs earlier um
because there are so many more people on
the finance committee in the house than
in the Senate the depth into which the
department budgets are explored is
significantly more on this side than the
other side now the specific issue of the
lapses is is a separate question and the
issue of um obtaining timely information
is another question but I I think that
that I would be a lot more comfortable
if we're talking about that kind of
communication and process issues rather
than rep plowing ground that I think at
least in the house is already being
plowed uh but I agree that finding out
exactly who who is plowing what is a
very worthwhile Enterprise and I think
that that's the starting point and even
if indeed I take the point that finance
division three is is quite large and
they go into quite a bit of depth I find
out about it when all the other members
of the House find out about it and I
would think as oversight we might be
involved somehow Senator rosenal well so
also while they're really busy now
building the next state
budget here we are 34s of the way
through it
and um just finding out basically last
week that the lapses are not what would
thought they would be there's an $81
million deficit you know on and on
so keeping on top of how it's going over
the two
years is really
important whether this committee is the
place to do it or whether the finance
committees are the place to do it or
even the fiscal committee I guess is
probably what we should discuss but you
know once once that budget's put to get
to
bed I don't know to what extent the
finance committees look at the
implementation good point representative
Woods oh thank you I think um my sense
is at the moment
that for this bium it would be much too
big a task to be a unless there's some
obvious need that would come up but it
may well be that if in fact we have a
mechanism in place at this committee to
look at designated segments then come
the next by we could potentially be a
very good player and very helpful both
to HHS and to the budget committee uh
but I guess I I I'm a little hesitant
about moving too fast and creating
perhaps more dust than than good as I
put together my guest list um
representative walner is the ranking
member of Finance
three Finance en of Finance entirely how
about of three
well
probably I I can chat with her we we we
chat
periodically get
along sure just can't go there because I
he look at up because she's taking notes
Senator gray I'm not opposed to having
this meeting outside of our monthly
meeting here um you know that would not
bother me at all
but is there anybody in this room right
now knowing that the projection is $47
million how much part of that $47
million is actually Health and Human
Services if you know raise your
hand since I don't see any hands going
up then somebody needs to provide that
oversight could you kindly state that
question again because I'm not going to
get it right and I can't type that fast
that's fine is just say it again knowing
that the estimate for the lapse is
$47 million
Lowes is there anyone
here is there anyone
here that can tell me
how much of
that is attributable
[Music]
to Health and Human Services thank you I
can check with her and let the record
show that nobody's hand went
up it she'll do
so go
ahead uh representative Weber if I may
ask a question uh it the way the
committee list
usually are is the first listed Democrat
usually the ranking member on the that's
correct so I believe it would be
representative laa tki although
representative wner was also listed but
she's listed after representative chorki
in division three ex offici and I think
perhaps like representative Wier
although I'm not sure representative
Wier is on all of the divisions and I
think it's quite possible that uh
representative wner is also on all of
the divisions uh in so far as she they
are able to split themselves into pieces
but um I I think I think I would check
with both uh representatives walner and
tersi and they can work it out perhaps
among themselves as to who is the best
person to speak about these particular
concerns and to to your point
representative wer was also listed in
division three along with representative
wner so when I had one of my wonderful
bills go to finance
3 um rep representative walner was
present and very helpful so she was in
the room
yeah I would like to
um have this is the last item on the
agenda next
month
um without objection or with only a few
objections I have no objection to the
discussion
right I
just sorry I I have no objection at all
to the discussion I think it's a very
useful and productive one as I first
heard the proposal it sounded very much
like a duplication
of what does happen um I am now clearer
that there is a slightly different focus
and whether or not I believe that this
is the appropriate place to do it it's
certainly well worth talking about
so represent as represent as Senator
gray says it's doesn't appear to be
being done anywhere else so if if this
is in the place perhaps finding a place
is a good discussion to
have Senator Rosenwald thank you I think
that the statute for this committee
gives you the authority to appoint
subcommittees as you choose we heard
from one today yes and so you could
create
a HHS budget oversight
subcommittee that could be composed
of anybody I mean not anybody but
wouldn't have to
be only from the members of this
committee
my suggestion is we put this item last
on the agenda because I'm sure um
attorney uh Williams has already got a
choca block thing from March I've seen
it but if we put it last and say look
we're probably going after 3:00 on this
prepare to stay if you're really
interested in this subject um prepare to
stay after
3:00 and if you're not you're not and if
you are please stay and
that we'll come up with something don't
s
good anything
else we all owe this committee 22
minutes
wow I think the committee ow owes us
some for prior meetings and um I think I
think we're doe some time off and
L representative you may have the rest
of the day
off just ification on time for wine and
cheese what kind of wine and what kind
of cheese if you bring the cheese I'll
whine with that I am I correct I'm sorry
for March am I correct we're meeting on
the 28th and I will correct correct the
minutes for this time yep okay that's
right thank you all right this meeting
is
adjourned
for for